hey guys this is Pete peppers with candy
crush soda saga tips calm and this is a
level 4:45 commentary walkthrough with
some tips this is one of the tougher
levels that came out in the last episode
so I was playing it again today and came
up with some tips and was able to get
died a lot easier than I did the first
time so I'll talk you through it here
when I noticed above all else and I'm
gonna pause this for a second is the ice
in between where the bottles are on the
sides is the hardest part and what holds
you up that end the part at the bottom
so I'm looking for combos that'll hit
these three in the middle that's my
whole plan and I'm not really worried
about popping the bottles as much I'll
get to that but like this strike Plus
wrap right here in the middle to take
out those side loses is a great way to
start so I'm gonna look for other things
like that the pieces are falling down
instead of up so like this is another
setup here another strike Plus wrap it
won't hit all of them and it'll hit some
of them and really you Sparkle shell
when we can I think I think they're I
would have liked to have set off the
right rat plus strike first but I wanted
to get the licorice off as at the same
time so looking back on it I maybe I
would have done that different but it
still worked out fine
now if you haven't gotten very far in
this level you know there's been there's
ten bears so they're stuck all on the
ice on the sides so eventually you have
to get them all free the reason why I
say the ones in the middle are so
important is because the you can't get
them by accident especially the one in
the very middle you're gonna have to hit
it with something and so as you can see
I'll just keep doing that excuse me and
colorbond plus and striped is always
going to be good but this isn't
particularly good because I have all
these yellows in the middle I know
they'll sort of clear that out and
they'll take out a lot of the bottom too
so you can see my first bears are
starting to pop out go ahead and make
that first
and now at this point it starts to just
be like a regular level we're going to
chip away at the ice on the sides and
then we'll just keep looking for combos
and I do like to put up especially if
you watch the other video that I did my
first one I do like to try to put up
some specials at the bottom of the board
fish plus a color bomb here will be good
because it'll go after the ice but yeah
like the way they come down it's order
than a zigzagging faction fashion on the
side you have to clear all the ice out
first then you have to actually make
some more stuff down there with it so
here I could use the wrapped striped
combo but I'm still trying to get that
middle part loosened up so I'm gonna
look around up top first and then I'll
get down to that eventually I shot off
the blue there one reason is because
that'll charge it up the fastest and the
other was because it didn't set off any
of the specials at the bottom of trying
to save for a little bit and this is a
mistake here because it set all that
stuff off I was just trying to set the
fish off but in the end it cleared out
the entire bottom for me so I can't I
can't worry too much I just really need
to get these last two pieces of ice
cleared out and a color bottom plus the
fish will do that pretty good right here
there's not a lot of yellow on the board
but there's enough I mean there's only
four ice cubes left so they'll all get
at least one yeah and now all the Bears
on the right side are free and we just
need to get one more
this is basically set off two more fish
and it'll it'll hit those two cubes
hopefully I'm kind of rolling with the
the sparkle shell here to see you
if it old if there's other moves I'm not
using it yet just because I can probably
charge it up two more times so it'll
come in handy I think to use them a
little more strategically towards the
end although here you know I don't
really have a spot so I'm gonna go ahead
and fire off that striped at the bottom
by clicking on orange and this is kind
of nice that I have two specials already
at the bottom and so I just have to make
another fish to get over there and eat
that last piece of ice
and that's kind of what I'm doing right
now is just looking because there's no
way to get I'll get to here I can make I
can make a fish it's gonna move down now
and then it's gonna be down by that so
that's not exactly ideal but I don't
really have anything else your color
bomb will set off the other [ __ ] if
I use it except for like if I use it for
yellow and the yellow it's not gonna
really do much so I'm gonna make the
fish and see if I can't figure out a way
to set it off without setting off the
other special at the bottom that I have
down there and that didn't exactly work
but it did set up another fish that I
have at the top of the screen now that
with the orange so I'll go ahead and do
that and I'll be able to set that off
right away and free my last bear so now
I have three moves to zigzag the rest of
the bears down oh I could do the rat
plus the stripe it'll go and take out a
lot of space and a few of the Bears will
come I don't think they'll all go down
no so we got that one we can move that
one by what's the sparks hell just by
getting rid of the blues and that and
that's the that's that's the great thing
about using it on blue 2 is that now he
look he um targets right back up so I
can use them again
and I'm gonna take out the orange
because that shouldn't be down once and
now I can just use my color bomb to
remove that yellow one that's sitting
right in front of him and the last bear
gets above the line so that's pretty
much it you know this like I said the
work on those middle areas with of the
ice and then try to have some specials
waiting for you at the bottom so you can
clear it out you might want
and then look at how they fall down
because they don't you know there's not
a way to like get them all to drop at
the exact same time so you you kind of
have to look at how that works but I
hope this helps it's a tough level like
I said and please subscribe to the
channel and like the video tell your
friends I'll be back with more videos
soon thanks